our next speaker is actor and director
Nick Searcy he got his start in New York
and off-broadway plays and he's gone on
to compile an impressive and long list
of television and film credits far too
many to mention here but allow me to
mention a few on television he's had
roles on la la I'll fly away return to
Lonesome Dove under Ali Nash Bridges the
West Wing Criminal Minds in Hawaii
five-o among many others I have to tell
you that my favorite television role of
his was as chief deputy u.s. marshal art
Mullen on the FX series justified hi
could I confess to being a bit nervous
that I'm gonna get something wrong in
this introduction and he's going to get
up here and yell at me the way he's deal
at Raylan Givens his multiple big-screen
credits include Days of Thunder fried
green tomatoes the fugitive castaway the
shape of water money ball and the best
of enemies he's also directed two movies
Carolina's Lo and most recently Gosnell
the trial of America's biggest serial
killer which was released in 2018 as
many of you know he's not afraid to
voices political opinions the fact that
their conservative opinions makes him
something of an outlier in Hollywood to
put it mildly he's been a guest on the
Andrew Klavan show louder with Crowder
in the Greg Gutfeld show and he has been
a guest host of the Rush Limbaugh radio
show his topic today is politics in
Hollywood would you please welcome to
the podium Nick Searcy
all right well good afternoon ladies and
gentlemen I just want to say thank you
for that introduction Timothy and how
honored I am to be here actors aren't
generally accepted into polite society
that often and I appreciate it very much
I've been a big fan of Hillsdale College
for a long time taking some of their
online courses I think I passed one of
them and I just want to thank Scott Hall
and and Larry Arne and and Matt and Kim
and for all they didn't bring in me here
it's really an honor and that being said
I as excited as I am to be here I can't
imagine how excited all of you must be
because I know you're all worried about
what Hollywood thinks about you you know
let me just say at the outset most of
the time we don't think about you at all
we're thinking about ourselves right
we're thinking things like you know does
this suit make me look fat and you know
maybe I should get that thing taken off
my face and that sort of thing that's
what we're generally thinking about it's
not you but I know it probably keeps you
up at night wondering like why don't the
people who are friends of Harvey
Weinstein think I'm a good person
but that's why I'm here that's why they
brought me here I in the into it with
apologies to Ronald Reagan here are
eight of the most terrifying words in
the English language I'm from Hollywood
and I'm here to help so being an outlier
as Timothy said I'm asked a lot of
questions and one of the things I'm
usually asked is why is Hollywood the
way it is why is it so monolithically
left especially when they are in one of
the most directly transactional
capitalist businesses in the world I
mean show business is really just an
episode of The Little Rascals
where Spanky and alfalfa want to put on
a show for the neighborhood and they're
gonna charge five cents and if it's a
good show they'll make money and if it's
a bad show they'll fail that's that's
what Hollywood is basically so it's pure
capitalism why don't they understand
that well there are various answers to
this question but I want to tell you one
story my uh my first cousin Gary I was
born in Hendersonville North Carolina
Nutt not that many years ago thank you
and my when I first moved to Hollywood
in the 90s my my cousin Gary came out to
visit me and Gary was in the weaving
business he had a he made rugs and he
went all over the world with this
business and sold in China overseas he
did very well with it but he was out in
Los Angeles for a trade show and he came
to me one night after he'd been there
for a couple of days and we'd had a few
drinks and he said you know what Nick
I've got a LA figured out I know why
everything is so screwed up here and I
said well tell me what it is and he says
well for a hundred years the craziest
people in America have moved to
Hollywood to try to become movie stars
and they've made it and they had kids
and I was wondering if he was including
me in that but but I do think that's
part of it but I also think that there's
a certain amount of groupthink and
intimidation going on here because it's
so difficult to get a job in this
business that the sheer numbers are just
completely unfavorable to a newcomer
it's practically impossible and the late
great comedian louis c.k had a great
line about this i mean he's not really
dead but he's just cancelled leftist on
leftist action is just irresistible to
me I can't stop watching it but he had a
great line about it and it was saying
that you want to be a professional actor
is like saying that you want to be a
cartoon dog wearing a jet pack it's just
about as likely so there's so many
reasons that a given actor doesn't get a
job you know you're too fat you're too
thin you're too old you're too smart and
that's just what happens to me a lot you
want to give them as few reasons as
possible to reject you right so it makes
more sense to join the club and that's
what the bullies that are the enforcers
in Hollywood do here they speak out
publicly constantly to send out the
signal that if you want to be in this
business you got to join the club in
your perfect example take Presidential
Medal of Freedom recipient Robert DeNiro
you thought I was going to say rush did
you
yeah did I mention that I guest-hosted
for rush once I don't know if I've
mentioned that yet but yeah Obama gave
DeNiro the same medal of freedom that
Trump gave mr. Limbaugh but of course
when Trump gave it to Rush he made all
the Democrats watch it which is
you
one more reason to love president Trump
but at the Tony Awards in 2018 Robert
DeNiro got up there and thought it would
be perfectly fine to repeatedly yell
duck Trump
I said duck with the D he didn't say
that
he said something else just to be clear
I said duck Larry I said duck and he's
called he's called Trump a gangster he's
called him Hitler he's called him
racist a white supremacist you know all
the same things that Democrats call
every single Republican president and
every presidential candidate going back
to even Romney and McCain when they
tried to convince us that they wanted to
beat Obama
but he mr. DeNiro also recently made
headlines when he said he hoped the
president would be hit in the face with
the flying bag of excrement although he
didn't say excrement leader and just
bear in mind when he says things like
that he really wants to hit everybody
who voted for Trump in the face that's a
lot of excrement so it's a good thing
that the Democrats have San Francisco
they're going to need it
but people are always asking me why do
these actors do this why do they
repeatedly just go out of their way to
insult the entire Trump electorate that
don't they care about their business
said well the first thing is I truly
believe a lot of it is is to intimidate
they want to intimidate everybody into
believing that if you want to be in show
business you got to support the
Democrats you got to hate the
Republicans and there's been a lot of
talk in the last few years and within
the circles of conservative Hollywood
which is a very small and intimate
circle about whether or not there is
actually a blacklist and the fear of
this blacklist is what led to the
establishment of the top secret
conservative fellowship group in LA that
you probably have all heard of so it's
not so secret but for most of the Obama
years this group was a kind of a safe
haven for actors and writers and people
like me who aren't left us and don't
believe stuff like well real socialism
has never been tried you know and it's
sort of functioned like an a a meeting
for Republicans it was like we would all
get together and we'd stand up and go hi
my name is Nick and I vote for
Republicans
I missed that Groupon but while there
may not be an actual blacklist there may
be but there may not be it doesn't
really matter because it doesn't need to
be because Hollywood is a town that's
run by fear and filled with cowards and
a whisper campaign is all it takes and
all the decisions are also made by
committee
so 14 people have to sign off on every
actor that they cast especially if it's
in a major role so if one person in that
room just goes I don't like that guy
that's it they don't even have to say
why they don't have to say I don't want
an accessory to do it because he voted
for Trump and he's not ashamed of it
they're they don't even have to say that
I just go I think we can do better than
him you know and now since Trump's been
elected he's torn the masks off of
everybody which is one of his super
powers but the leftists in Hollywood
don't even bother to hide it anymore
they they they blast their their
McCarthyite tendencies all over the
media and and they know do that knowing
that they're going to get more work not
less they're going to get more work if
they do that for example Trump
fundraiser in Beverly Hills last
September when it was announced Will and
Grace got involved
you remember willing grace yeah I never
watched it either
but Debra Messing felt comfortable
asking for names she tweeted please
print a list of all attendees the public
has a right to know
and then we'll got involved eric
mccormack hey The Hollywood Reporter he
said kindly report on everyone attending
this event so the rest of us can be
clear about who we don't want to work
with Thanks and at least he said thanks
but there are so many well-known actors
people that you would recognize by face
if not by name who they say to me all
the time man I agree with you but I
would never say it out loud because I
know it hurt my bottom line and you're
crazy and they are undoubtedly correct
and smarter than me but Hollywood used
to make a movie about McCarthyism about
every 15 minutes it's like their
favorite subject the Nero himself made
one called guilty by suspicion in 1991
and the reason it's one of their
favorite subjects is that it allows
leftist to paint themselves as the
abused victims of evil Republicans even
though it was their own colleagues in
Hollywood that blacklisted them it
wasn't wasn't Congress it was the people
they worked with so why do they act like
in real life
like the bad guys in their movies that
they make and it's because they're
rewarded for it if you make some vile
ignorant hateful statement about a
Republican that's a resume enhancement
in Hollywood that that shows you're in
the club shows you're one of them like
it's better than an audition it's better
than a billboard on Sunset Boulevard and
the more hateful it is the better the
more Alec Baldwin attacks Trump the more
Emmy nominations he gets that's the way
it works and they never pay a price for
it they are insulated from paying a
price for it if you're a name that
producers are willing to pay millions of
dollars for like DeNiro you're
considered your royalty and no one in
Hollywood can say
excrement to you and the studios have
protected themselves to buy cross
collateralizing everything for example
if you feel like Game of Thrones and you
subscribe to HBO you're also subsidizing
Bill Maher and vice and countless
documentaries about how wonderful Nancy
Pelosi is and how awful Republicans are
and that's just the way they've done it
they can make one Avengers movie that
makes a billion dollars and that gives
them a chance to make a bunch of other
movies that they're just making for each
other they're just making to show off
and say look I'm in the club look how
woke I am look at this movie I made so
that's how it works and so the message
gets sent if you want to succeed you got
to be in the club and if you weren't in
the club they're not gonna let you in if
you have a story that you want to tell a
movie that you want to make and it
doesn't fit their ideology ideology
that's a tough word they won't touch it
either they won't touch it or they'll
put you in a box
a lot of the studios have created these
divisions that are for faith-based films
and so they put it over there and say
we're gonna make these films for those
people because they'll probably pay for
it but we don't want them to be
associated with our mainstream films
right they put it over to the side so
they can make a little money on it but
they've identified it they've targeted
it and they've dismissed it and what
that ultimate effect is is that they are
marching down the field of culture
unopposed left never wants to win fair
and square right they they don't they
can't do it they can't win on their
ideas so they have to clear the field
that's why they want to silence
everybody that speaks out against them
and they don't want to have movies made
that are against their ideology they
throw the word fascism around and they
probably couldn't define it if their
next government check depended on it
because they are the fascists and they
don't realize so what this all means is
my friends we as conservatives we have
got to get in this game somehow we have
got to get in the field of entertainment
we got to put the pads on in the helmet
on and get out there and hit somebody
like my football coach in high school
used to say he used to say you know
those people over there on the other
side they put their pants on one leg at
a time just like we do they don't set
them up over there in the corner and run
and jump in to him they're just like us
so that's that's how we got a look at
the Hollywood left we're just as good at
it as they are but the left has had this
long march through the institution's
virtually unopposed
except for Hillsdale College and I wish
I could say for places like Hillsdale
College but I can't because there isn't
any other place like Hillsdale College
and that all of that has brought us to
this point where the Democrat Party is
about to nominate a full-blown unashamed
communist for president they're about to
nominate Bernie Sanders they rave about
Putin and they're about to nominate a
communist and when you see all these
young lunatics that are at the Sanders
rallies ripping their jerks off and
grabbing the mic away from him it's you
you have to wonder how did this happen
how did we get to this point where we
have so many historically ignorant young
people who embrace socialism well my
friend Jesse Kelly who's a talk radio
show host out of Houston he put it like
this start going to a government school
at the age of six keep going until
you're 22 spend seven hours a day
learning how bad America sucks and
almost nothing about the deadly evils of
communism and then you'll understand
Bernie Sanders so now if you add on top
of that the fact that every bit of
mainstream entertainment that they
consume from the time they're old enough
to watch Teletubbies is it reinforces
the same ideas Republicans are racist
Christians or hypocrites
progressivism is compassionate
America's evil and imperialist there
that that's constantly beat into their
heads but there is a vastly underserved
audience out there that has an appetite
for entertainment that does not demean
them or our country and we have to make
entertainment for this audience and we
have to find a delivery system for it
now a couple of years ago I directed a
movie that did go around the system
called Gosnell I think a few of you
clapped when you saw everybody who
didn't see that movie get out
but Gosnell is a movie about the
real-life case of an abortion doctor
Kermit Gosnell who was convicted in
Philadelphia in 2013 of multiple crimes
including murder for snipping the necks
of babies after they had been born which
is now legal in New York but we had to
go around the system the money was
raised on IndieGoGo it was successfully
raised in 2014 we shot it in 2015 the
movie was finished by early to mid 2016
and it took nearly two and a half years
to find a distributor to release the
movie in October of 2018 and that
happened we had a very reputable sales
agent on board he had sold a lot of
movies in the past and he watched the
finished film he says this is a good
movie it should sell very quickly he got
one offer for $50,000 and that and he
got responses like this it's a good
movie and I'm sure there's an audience
for it but I have to work with these
people on Monday so the distribution
companies are afraid that they'd be
kicked out of the club if they were
involved with Gosnell and in the
advertising when we had a release date
the advertising we got pushback on that
Facebook blocked our ads
NPR refused to run ads that that contain
the word abortion doctor lifetime in
hallmark to two networks whose audience
would intersect with our audience they
wouldn't run any of the ads the only
network would that would take our ads
was guess what Fox News that's right and
we got some airtime from talk radio
glenn glenn beck gave us a great
hour-long spot and and my close personal
friend rush talked about the movie did I
mention that I guest-hosted for running
but even given that resistance given all
that stuff Gosnell when it was released
in 600 theaters we were the number one
indie film in the country that weekend
and we cracked the top 10 overall and
the reviews were typically polarized
half of them hated it half of them loved
it but the ones that hated it slammed it
as right-wing propaganda of course but
the really surprising thing about the
reviews was the number of them films
released generally in that many theaters
600 of morge always get at least a
hundred reviews and some get up to 200
Gosnell got 11 reviews eleven and they
ultimately they treated the movie like
they treated the trial they just tried
to ignore it they pretended that it
didn't exist we tried to make a film
that was based as much on possum as much
as possible on actual court transcripts
and direct interviews with the principal
real-life players tried to stay close to
the facts because we didn't want to be
dismissed as propaganda but guess what
they called it propaganda anyway I'm
gonna show a clip from the movie now
that and this is a clip of the scene
when I read the script this is why I
wanted to direct the film is because it
was so it was just information that I
didn't know I didn't really know what a
real abortion was and I thought that was
important information that everybody
should have no matter what side of the
issue you're on so this is a scene with
Gosnell defense
cross-examining a a good abortion doctor
an abortion doctor who's legal and who
was called by the prosecution to show
the difference between what Gosnell did
and illegal abortion so Ted doctor North
how many abortions would you say you
performed in your career I have
performed over 30,000 abortions Wow
and the second trimester what method of
abortion do you use mostly D&E dilation
and evacuation yes
dilation is where you soften and widen
the woman's cervix correct that is
correct once the fetus grows larger it's
very important that we do that to
prevent the cervix from tearing as the
fetus is removed and then you evacuate
the fetus you remove it from the womb
yes but first we have to make sure that
it's not a live birth oh of course of
course how do you do that well we inject
potassium chloride into the heart of the
fetus hmm with one of these correct yes
Your Honor I'd like to introduce defense
exhibit 1a on the screen ma'am publish
you may publish now this is a sonogram
of a 23 week old fetus and so when you
inject the fetus do you put the needle
here no here yes right there and that
stops the heart that's correct
and then you use forceps you use these
and you reach up in there and you grab a
hold of an arm or a leg or whatever and
you pull on it until it comes out or
comes off and correct that's correct but
with larger fetuses they remain intact
of course because the heads bigger makes
it more difficult what do you do then we
use a machine to suction out the gray
matter the gray matter the brains so you
suction out the brains and then what
happens then the skull collapses and the
fetus can be removed right now isn't it
true that sometimes in order to get the
suction machine into the fetus you have
to use a pair of scissors to make a hole
in the back of the neck sometimes this
happens yes so before when you said that
you'd never cut the neck of a feeble
stirring to a live birth oh okay yeah I
get it now
have you ever had a live birth during an
abortion attempt doctor no I have not
because we listened to the sonogram to
ensure that the fetal heart has stopped
well what if you made a mistake
we don't well what if you did objection
hypothetical your honor your honor she's
a medical expert I'd like to have her
opinion overruled
I'm going to allow the question but stay
on point counselor what would you do
the baby was out and it was breathing we
would issue comfort care comfort care
can you define that for us that's
keeping the fetus warm and comfortable
eventually it will pass eventually it
would pass so basically you'd you'd let
it die seemed like it'd be more humane
to just take a pair of scissors
objection
withdraw the question your honor
I know that's one of my favorite actors
- I love that guy
but that's the scene that most of the
negative reviewers called right-wing
propaganda Gosnell defense attorney was
essentially saying what's the difference
the result is the same and that's what
he said during the actual trial and the
man was a pro-choice attorney he was who
was making the argument but the left
isn't interested in that they don't want
those facts to be out there the entire
subject is something they don't want to
talk about the only thing you need to
know about abortion in the hollywood
narrative is that if you oppose it or
even want restrictions on it you are a
racist who hates women and you can't be
in the club that's it
so if we want to tell our stories we've
got to build a new hollywood because
that one's broken and I don't just mean
content we have to build a delivery
system to bring the content to the
audience that wants to see it and I
think the first step that we have to
make to achieve this is that we as
conservatives have got to recognize the
power of storytelling the left has
dominated that field forever
conservative investors are generally not
disposed towards financing feature films
or television shows that aren't
documentaries and it's not just because
their risky investments which they are
it's because we don't perceive the value
of storytelling now Jesus spoke in
parables he didn't come out and just say
here are the facts people although he
did that sometimes but he he taught
through storytelling and that's what we
have to that's what we have to learn
conservatives like to fund news networks
and they like but not sitcoms because
they don't see the value in it friend of
mine put it like this if the
Conservatives were building the library
it would be all nonfiction
and if the Liberals built the library it
would all be novels and poems and short
stories and of course the Liberals
library would be a lot more fun to visit
and that that mean that's where I would
go because it'd be a lot more popular
because storytelling is popular
storytelling helps people learn I'm
about to use one of the most overused
quotes in 21st century conservative
speeches but that's not going to stop me
Andrew Breitbart once famously said
politics is downstream of culture we
have let the Hollywood left to find the
culture for at least 50 years but we
have an opening now because Hollywood
has destroyed itself they've revealed
themselves by expressing their seething
contempt for everyone who disagrees with
them they've alienated themselves from a
large portion of America because now
when you hear when a middle America
hears the words movie star they don't
think anymore oh that's that's someone
beautiful and handsome who acts in
movies and makes me feel emotions that I
don't generally feel about no we don't
think that anymore when somebody hears
movie star it's like oh yeah that's just
another idiot who hates me because I
won't vote for socialism so they've
they've they've really left us a huge
opening so how do we do it how do we
build a new Hollywood well my idea is
that the entertainment business needs
its own rush limbaugh whose show I
hosted on December 27
2017 but here's here's what I mean by
that for for all the young
whippersnappers out there and I'm
there's a couple of them but it's really
hard for people who weren't alive back
then to understand what life was like
before rush limbaugh because there was
no one and I mean no one like him
there was no Fox News there was no
Hannity there wasn't even really talk
radio as a national format there was no
alternative to the alphabet networks and
the the biased news reporting that they
do and rush by himself pretty much
destroyed the monopolies that the Left
had on the news business and his effect
on the culture has been immeasurable and
that's why they've tried and failed for
30 years to destroy him because they
know how effective he is rush changed
Andrew Breitbart Russ changed me and
basically we have to accept the fact
that we are the counterculture now not
them not Hollywood
we are the Sex Pistols people we are the
punk rockers and we need to pick up this
mantle you know if if there had not
always think if Rush Limbaugh had
existed during the Nixon years he might
not have resigned he might have just
thought hey that guys on the radio
fighting maybe I'll fight too you know
and I would argue right now that without
Rush there would be no President Trump
that's how much he changed the culture
and speaking of President Trump because
at the end of the day we all know
everything is about President Trump one
of the reasons that the left is so
ineffective against him and why they
hate him so much is that President Trump
comes from the culture he doesn't come
from politics he comes from the culture
he had a reality so for years American
people got got comfortable with him they
got to know him a little bit and they
got a sense that this is a real person
it's not a focus group phony like like
almost every single politician that we
can
like me
and like rush Trump does not filter
himself he doesn't put on airs
he doesn't focus group his thoughts he
just talks to us right tells us what he
thinks whether it's on Twitter or
whether it's walking to the helicopter
going no not you fake news fake news no
shut up no not you
don't be rude don't be rude you know my
favorite thing about him and they did
the Daytona 500 wasn't that great so
good I mean you ruined the day for the
five or six Democrats who actually
watched NASCAR but other than that just
great but in closing I have a candidate
that I would like for you to consider
backing as the Rush Limbaugh of
entertainment he has worked in Hollywood
for almost 30 years
he's already directed one movie that
affected the culture positively he's
getting ready to direct two movies in
the next 18 months one one set in the
world of gospel quartet music which of
course is very sexy subject that
Hollywood won't touch and then after
that a movie about the Battle of Kings
Mountain in the Revolutionary War which
is the first battle that America won and
now he's working with a group called
American Pictures to make this slate of
movies like this that will be pro faith
Pro America and that's why Hollywood
doesn't want to do them that's right
I mean
this man is also working with a group
that's creating a new streaming service
and a content platform called creado
which will compete with Netflix and
YouTube and it'll do so without
censoring conservative voices or
narratives and he is also the biggest
Hollywood star to have ever guest hosted
the Rush Limbaugh program Ted
thank you for having me for those of you
that brought your checkbooks I'll be at
the bar I'm from Hollywood and I'm here
to help thank you
and if anybody has any questions that I
can't answer
wonderful congratulations sir
thank you how many years will it take to
overcome that Democrat Florida Democrat
Hollywood to making it a Republican
Hollywood I don't know if we're ever
gonna see that but I really do think
though that there's an opening to create
an alternative to Hollywood and maybe
the alternative to Hollywood will
overtake it I think that's the way to do
it I don't think they're gonna let us
join them we're gonna have to go around
them or over them we open big it was a
pleasure meeting you last night I that
person is not into a shameful promotion
I am an actor too but not as good as you
you are a very good actor and uh well
thank you and I just wanna let you know
that um I served in the Vietnam War I
didn't fight didn't almost lose my life
but I did serve as no certified OB
technician to see what I saw up on that
film on abortion really affected me if
there's anything I can do I would do it
and my career hasn't taken off because
I'd let them know who I was a
conservative Christian Republican and if
I can just shamefully endorse myself
to be help you I'll keep you in mind
is an unanswerable question that dennis
prager
does not know the answer I want your
answer as to why the Jewish people are
ultra liberal in the progressives this
is a tough question
well I can't yeah you're right it's
unanswerable but I'll fall back on my
friend rush who says basically liberals
are always liberals first doesn't matter
what else they are they're liberals
first they're leftist first so even the
Jewish people any Christian people
anybody if they're they're liberal
they're liberals before their religion
but my question is Phil & Shoots
wouldn't he be a champion of what you're
trying to do whoo Phil and shoots the
colorado billionaire who's owned
railroads oil and he's produced
Christian movies uh-huh and I'm just
made me think of him yeah I'm not
familiar with him personally but I will
say that one of the problems with
defining movies as Christian movies
means that no one but Christians are
gonna go see it right so that's kind of
one of the things that we're trying to
overcome they'll they want to put us in
the box and say that's a Christian movie
if you're not a Christian don't go see
it right so we need to start making
movies that sneak up on people you know
that have the message in there but they
don't they aren't just identified with a
big like you know that's a Christian
movie you know yeah I do but if he's got
that kind of money I do need to know
yeah well though I'll overlook that
yes thank you
I've got cash accept that yes absolutely
more seriously can you will you comment
on the Clarence Thomas movie that came
out January 31st and is not very widely
distributed yes I well you know I don't
know that much about that specific movie
but I do know you know Dennis Prager
came out with a documentary called no
safe spaces which got a little bit of
play but yeah a lot of people did see it
but I think part of the problem me
personally this is just my opinion I
think this documentaries have a very
limited appeal and and some are better
than others obviously some do do better
business than others but I think really
if we want to really affect the culture
we're gonna have to start telling them
stories with big stars like me in it you
know so my husband and I have a hill
cell graduate from four years ago and
she is passionately pursuing trying to
get into acting of course you know as
her mom and dad we're I'm just trying to
support her but after hearing what you
said today I you know I don't know
whether to have a lot of hope for her
but I still want to give her
encouragement but I would like to hear
if you were her dad what would you what
kind of words would you say to her I
would say to her
the world needs plumbers
we don't need actors we got enough no
but seriously what I would say to what I
say to a most everybody who asked me
that question create your own content
that's that's how the world is now
that's how people become stars now in
Hollywood they don't do it by doing a
play and having an agent come see them
that's the old way the way they do it
now they create their own content they
get 10 zillion Instagram followers and
they get good at making films and being
a storyteller and being a creator of
media and so that that if she could do
that I think that's the best way who
else
a question on the speakers left left to
the speaker I'm sorry
lights are in my eyes thank you for your
wonderful presentation I have two things
I'd like to say first of all the
abortion that was very powerful very
powerful all of us I just don't know why
we can't just start not using public
funds because what you just showed I
paid for that is the hurtful part of it
second thing I want to say is Harrison
Ford who we all I understand he was
gonna have this movie call of the wild
what little boy didn't read call of the
wild or girl I was so excited to tell my
husband there's gonna be a new movie
that we might actually go to call of the
wild and he was all excited Harrison
Ford or whatever Harrison Ford
three days later God tell us will you
tell us what he did
well how he screamed obscenities about
Trump when he was supposed to be talking
about the movie we will not go to that
movie well yeah
well this is kind of what I was talking
about is that they Harrison Ford's not
gonna feel any consequences for that
he's already got his right the reason he
says that stuff is to Telegraph to
everybody else I'm in the club I'm one
of you guys you know and I'm not saying
that Harrison port doesn't actually
believe what he's saying I'm saying that
that gives him permission to speak that
way because he knows he doesn't have to
answer to you he doesn't have to answer
the audience you know he's already got
his money so he's gonna say whatever he
thinks and if you don't like it he
doesn't care and that's that's why
there's an opening for us now Hollywood
universally is doing this they don't
care that we have a bad reaction to
being called the names that they call us
right they've already got theirs we got
to create ours we have a question on the
speaker's right Nick hi what's the
budget for your project one is uh well
I'm we're working at a 12 million dollar
budget for the gospel quartet movie
right now and about eight million for
the Revolutionary War movie which may
not make a lot of sense but if you if
you saw what we had to work with you'd
know why and we do have a company that
company American Pictures I'm working
with them we're trying to raise the
money that way if anybody's got any
money you can talk to me later
but no it's we're working at about and
what they're trying to do is raise
enough money to make a slate of film so
that the risk is minimized you don't
you're not just putting all your eggs in
one film you're making a slate of films
that all have the same kind of basic
thrust which is we actually like America
first of all I have a Jewish friend who
believes that God sent trouble to save
our country my mother thinks this too
hi mom yep the other thing is there's
another movie made true that this true
about a girl a woman who was very
instrumental in an abortion clinic and
very much for it until she witnessed an
abortion mm-hmm and then she was so
against it she was able to close all
closed down that clinic I think it was
in Texas and I can't think of the name
of the movie but very good that's it
unplanned yeah it was a movie called
unplanned which the biggest mistake they
made was not putting me in that would
have been a lot better question on the
speaker's left
you obviously want money but in addition
to that have you given consideration to
developing a group of people who writing
the kinds of stories you would like to
see and make into films yeah I mean
there's a network of us yeah that we are
there's a that's going on you know we we
are kind of working on I've got four or
five projects right now I'm trying to
develop and and I know people that are
doing the same thing and and you know
it's it's it's a matter of we're going
into uncharted territory here you know
we have to find a way in and that's part
of what the creado idea that I was
talking about which is a platform that
will will accept our movies and allow us
to deliver them to to conservatives to
people who are sick of Harrison Ford
talking about them the way he does and
that sort of thing so question on your
speakers right hi thank your response
kind of is in line with what I was gonna
ask if you make these films and don't
get the distribution
are there other avenues that you can
release them and make money yeah and
that's what that's that's part of the
infrastructure that that has to be built
I mean it's gonna take it's gonna take
some serious money you know because
basically what you're building is a
studio as well as the content provider
as well as the distribution system so
we're gonna need a lot of money
everybody get ready it's Clint Eastwood
part of your collaborative group it
seems to me like he would be a good
addition to it he's not already well
Clint Eastwood doesn't need a group I
mean that's the one thing about
Hollywood too is like with people like
Clint Eastwood and even Mel Gibson in
some regard you know that if you are
that big you don't you know they'll
they'll go then they know that your
movie is going to sell regardless so
they're gonna do business with that
they're gonna do business with Clint
Eastwood right but that's that's
different than sort of doing business
with a relative nobody like me we're
hearing a lot about what's happening and
and and the difficulty of it but haven't
heard how do we as individuals as a
society impact and influence the change
or make to help make the change happen
that's another kind of side question as
we understand there's quite a number of
people in Hollywood who have the same
belief as you and we may be you might
want to comment on that yeah I mean I
think we're all gonna have to come
together at some point I mean one of the
characteristics of conservatives is that
we're all about individual liberty and
and freedom and sometimes that doesn't
make us the best collaborators you know
so I think in some ways we we we do have
a trouble kind of all getting together
because a lot of us are thinking well
that guy's parts bigger than mine or you
know what what what is my role here so I
don't know if that answers your question
but we we have to find a way to come
together on a common goal basically
question to the speaker is left in the
back I and thank you very much does this
attitude cut across through Theodore
Symphony or is that beyond what you can
speak to know I think it does I mean I
think that I was talking about this at
lunch I mean I think there's a certain
type of person that is attracted to
going into the theater and those are
theater these are people that are maybe
more storytellers more they live in an
empathetic world they want to you know
feel what other people feel and present
that and and so that makes them less
analytical I would say then people who
look on at the theater from the outside
who go into more skilled sort of medical
fields or that kind of thing that you
know you you hear about a lot of child
actors you don't hear about a lot of
child brain surgeons you know there's a
there's a certain type of person and I'm
one of those people I was attracted to
that I wanted to be an actor from the
time I was 12 years old I just didn't
know that you couldn't also be a
conservative I had to find that out the
hard way I have heard one definition of
an actor right here where I'm sorry is a
person who who is told how to walk or to
stand what to do and what to say and
then they turn around and tell us how we
should be ever mind I think it was the
Seinfeld line Jerry Seinfeld how's this
lying about you know what the Oscars
it's like Oh so-and-so's a genius says
that actors aren't geniuses you know
basically somebody said okay come out of
your trailer right now after you've put
on these clothes say these lines stand
right here say what we told you to say
he did it he's a genius we have time for
one more question
you had mentioned distributing or
getting the information out on social
media such as
Facebook Instagram Twitter has that been
effective for you
I noticed that James Woods was banned
from Instagram and he's suddenly back in
all his glory so I don't know how that
works or how that would work for you
well I'm on Twitter if you guys want to
you guys it's a knife fight on my
Twitter timeline but if you want to go
there I mean yeah that those things are
available to a certain degree there is
what they call shadow banning on Twitter
I don't really know that much about it
I don't I don't necessarily use Twitter
as some sort of useful tool I just use
it for fun I just like going on there
and slapping these left that's around
poking teasing them a little bit you
know so I don't know if it's really an
effective marketing tool although you
know people do use it that way
what I'm talking about is more about the
real infrastructure of content and
delivery that's that's what I want to do
and Twitter's not really about that
please join me in thanking mr. Searcy
thank you thanks so much I had a
wonderful time thank you